台灣股市今天一度暴跌千點
46000保衛戰嗎 為什麼
原來是美債殖利率狂升
再不升息就完蛋
可是升了息
台股好像也完蛋 怎麼辦
進退維谷 怎麼會這樣子
第三個 今晚CPI通膨數據如何解讀
這三個其實都是同一件事情
就是要不要升息
這是聚焦到今天晚上的
因為最近戰爭
大家可能比較少去討論戰爭了
這個戰爭 很簡單
什麼意思
從荷姆茲海峽打到紅海
越打越大
這個有點出乎我想像
我沒想到川普這麼硬
應該是說川普一直羞辱人家
我覺得常常看到川普這件事
我告訴自己
人也不要太臭屁
雖然他有能力
但是他也常常搞砸很多事情
創造很多事情也搞砸很多事情
我不要講那麼多廢話
我是要告訴你
台灣股市現在跌
就是因為要升息
我給你結論 就是要升息
而且升息機率很高
沒有78%那麼高
也沒有87%
但是有72% 這是9月的升息機率
可是12月呢
基本上還有可能升息到2碼
12月 從現在開始一整年
不再升息的機率不到5%
所以資金會被抽走
加上美債越滾越大
像滾雪球一般
美債殖利率也是狂噴
所以投資朋友
這個跟大家講
所以你去看這個東西 來
給你看這個圖 來
你們要看這個圖
所以今天晚上 記得一件事
今天晚上CPI通膨數據
對 我忘了自我介紹
要自我介紹嗎 總是要一下啦
新粉絲可能不知道我
應該全台灣沒有人不知道我啦
我是全台灣唯一百萬
甚至140萬的分析師
郭哲榮投資長 好不好
去打聽一下什麼叫哲哲
好啦 我們來看一下
美國財政部提高美債回購規模
到60億美元
市場反應不如預期
而且你看這個10年期
美債殖利率狂飆
已經預期了有沒有看到
預期會升息
你們去看一下
越有美感的人會喜歡我的節目
你看我做的圖就是比人家漂亮
真的啦
雖然現在AI圖大家都做得不錯
大概都有60分以上的水準
可是你會覺得郭哲榮做的圖
我們做的圖 AI的圖
就是比一般分析師
我們摩爾做的AI圖
封面也好
就是做的比一般分析師好看
這是事實 好
美債殖利率這邊拉起來
這個跟你講 10年期美債殖利率
市場原先預測 大概
為什麼 因為市場原先預測
大概購債80到100億美元
我要購債 我購債以後就把價格打下去
不是價格打下去
我購債以後對不對
對 我購債以後把他提高價格
提高價值 把殖利率打下去
這樣沒錯吧
這個殖利率跟債的價格是成反比
現在公債的殖利率往上揚
價格殺下去了
公債殖利率往上揚
那其實暗示了要升息
這樣懂不懂
不懂沒關係 多聽幾次
反正公債殖利率不要一直往上 好不好
你去再想一件事
你看公債殖利率往上
如果假設到10%
我幹嘛做股票 對不對
你突然覺得台灣50很難做了
就會有資金去買公債了
這樣懂不懂
就有吸收資金了 這樣懂不懂
這樣用比較簡單的作法跟大家講
能怎麼辦
債務已經大於40兆美元了
還有AI吸這個債務 好不好
AI去吸這個債務
AI把這個借錢
把很多資金吸走
變成對美國公債的吸引力又不夠
然後川普每天罵加拿大
你是加拿大人
你會想要買他的美國公債嗎
你是加拿大政府
你會買美國公債嗎
你是中國 你會想買美國公債嗎
所以川普在亂搞
你記得一件事 川普在亂搞
我是跟大家講
我做事情 我都是給他留一線情
真的 我跟大家講做事情 做生意
像譬如說人家攻擊我
除非逼不得已
我其實不喜歡提告
你看搞到身體也不好
真的身體不好
昨天法院看到他也不開心
我也祝福他
但是他搞錯對象 他惹錯對象了
就像我昨天也很生氣
詐騙集團把我的IG跟Threads
全部下架
趕快請助理
我昨天兩個圖片趕快生給我
應該這邊有
詐騙集團把我的那個
詐騙集團 請助理趕快給我
詐騙集團把我兩個帳號
IG Threads 臉書
全部都 連同之前的臉書
全部都毀掉
很厲害
我之前說要打藍勾勾
他自己就創造一個圖片裡面有藍勾勾
是帳號旁邊要藍勾勾
然後我說以我的帳號為主
IG s178178
現在沒有藍勾勾
被他們暫時毀掉 很厲害
我不知道他們怎麼檢舉的
可是我說老實話
我其實也可以每天找記者
我也可以每天找立委
像新加坡一樣
以後名人要加入臉書
要臉部辨識
這樣你們其他詐騙集團
就不能模仿我了
某種方面我也不想要逼人太絕
可是我覺得反而是
詐騙集團逼我太過分
那我也不得不適當的反擊
太誇張了啦
一個帳號
我每天刪100個郭哲榮假帳號
差不多啦
或郭哲榮週邊的
或者用人頭戶
這是哲哲的帳號 哲哲什麼的
一天100個
很誇張
當然我是希望詐騙集團不要太誇張
但是被氣到不行
因為我搜尋郭哲榮
發現郭哲榮好多案件喔
司法院可以搜尋你知道
郭哲榮好多案件
你知道什麼案件嗎 最多案件是
用我的名字去詐騙
我真的希望政府
很多人不要談到藍綠白 我很不喜歡
年底也要選舉了是不是
什麼時候要選舉 年底要選舉了
真的把這件事搞定好不好
就是說直接要求臉書
臉書真的最過分
在台灣沒有代理人
你知道為什麼我最喜歡Google嗎
我現在也很喜歡LINE了
因為他們有代理人
我可以直接去認證他們
所以你要記得一件事情
最好的是YouTube
YouTube講的話基本上是真的
99.99%
然後那個LINE
現在也有認證 LINE有打勾
現在有認證 也是一樣
來 我們來講一下喔
這個不好意思喔
我是不想花這個時間
浪費我的時間
搞得我心情很不好
而且又加上
今天其實我是不太想錄了 我沒騙大家
所以我今天錄影的時間會比較短
先等一下
我今天錄影時間比較短
所以投資朋友 為什麼
昨天看到按讚
每天我唸才按2000個讚
以後再這麼少
昨天2000個讚
點閱率還OK嗎 可以
還不錯啦
你們按讚嘛
按讚我才會有那種感覺
點閱率也更好嘛
所以我今天會錄比較短一點
你們再不按讚以後就錄更短
這是唯一官方LINE
助理以後給我解析度比較高的
重新做沒關係
這個要盾牌
盾牌打勾 好不好
我覺得用盾牌不太好
以後助理要寫說有打勾 好不好
一樣這是白勾勾
以後用白勾勾來講 好不好 助理
所以投資朋友
你以後要認清楚這邊有個白勾勾
這個都是合法
你有沒有發現
現在很多分析師在模仿我了
我也是全台灣第一個認證的
點這邊以後 這邊寫已認證
記得LINE這邊已認證
然後現在LINE
好像年底之前要用電話
所以以後LINE
就是所有的帳號要用電話
所以以後LINE會越來越安全
你只要點我的照片以後沒有已認證
沒有這個白勾勾
上面沒有白勾勾就是假的
就這麼簡單
不得不花時間
因為我覺得花這個時間沒意思
又不能解盤 對不對
然後對會員沒有幫助
來 這個最誇張 你看
他把我檢舉過後
你有沒有看到 很厲害喔
是他檢舉的 因為
我為什麼知道是他檢舉的
因為我帳號一不見他馬上發文章
你看他很厲害喔
跟大家報告一件事
這是用我的照片
今天原本的Threads突然被大量檢舉
現在已經沒有辦法正常使用
我也很無奈
網路上詐騙集團這麼多
詐騙帳號這麼多
他就是詐騙啦 還寫這麼厲害
帳號沒了不代表我不做了
然後記得要加
這個帳號就是我的新家
厲不厲害
你記得一件事情
我不會在臉書跟Threads
我現在臉書也沒在經營了
我不會在Threads
留言叫你加我的LINE
或怎麼樣
或者加Threads
記得一件事
我不會主動去加你
我很紅 我不需要
再講一次
我不會在臉書跟Threads
留言叫你加我的LINE
或臉書或Threads
我很紅 我不需要
有叫你要加的
主動叫你加的
那都是詐騙集團
我的帳號我就放在這邊
你要不要加隨便你
最準的一切以YouTube官方說法為主
因為YouTube在台灣有代理人
就是打電話去 有人接
臉書沒有人接 好不好
臉書沒有人 他不願意派人 好不好
LINE現在也有人了
這個跟大家講
好不好 這個都把他把握住這個行情
扯遠了 還是要花時間
我們在中間 我們在錄影
現在差不多12點多 1點的時間
盤在走 還在殺
國巨在殺 怎麼看
哲哲你的股票現在變很慘
我覺得你不要去想這些東西
環球晶怎麼看
環球晶還是收紅K啦
有上去一點點啊 是不是
不會 跌深就是最好的買點
我再講一件事 來
你們都看 我是看很長的
我財富能累積是我看很長
深呼吸 我今天其實真的不想錄影
因為心情不好
第一個被詐騙集團搞到心情不好
我還是希望詐騙集團真的喔
哲哲要這樣子的話
再搞下去的話
哲哲會真的找記者
一直找立委
會真的
因為我覺得這是未來趨勢 遲早的
他們要逼我加速 真的沒必要
真的哲哲之後
會加速這個新加坡一樣
就是我要名人帳號就是臉部辨識
要身份證臉部辨識
才能開這個官方帳號
所以以後也檢舉不了
詐騙集團也不能申請
我是覺得大家彼此都留一條路
雖然詐騙集團很過份
但是我覺得 我也不是那種
我是很討厭詐騙集團
但是我不是說斬草除根
一定要怎麼樣
因為這種很多事情
一輩子也處理不完
但是也不能太囂張
囂張到一定要把我毀滅掉
他們把我毀滅掉對他們有什麼好
我一句話說
以後Threads 臉書都不要看了
那全部都假的
那不是更容易被檢舉 對不對
或者以後真的是政府硬起來
現在政府已經對LINE硬起來了
接下來我覺得臉書有機會
只要我不斷的宣導 真的
來啦 先跟大家講
就這樣子吧 來
心情被他們搞得很差
某種方面
他們是用我的名聲還檢舉我
算了 算了 算了
是真的很生氣
不過最生氣 最難過的是
投資朋友你們要多給我按讚
我現在真的是做事情 每天很累
我都覺得沒意義
就是太紅了
你看昨天那個法院也是太紅了
奇怪 我就是紅
紅到我處理一些不是股票的事情
我很生氣 我也很累
當然我也是告訴自己還好
所以我今天簡短一下 我要休息
你不用擔心
下禮拜一我就恢復正常
今天晚上如果有大事情
我還是會寫文章或者錄影片
我覺得今天晚上
美股應該不太妙
CPI通膨會不太好 好不好
先跟大家講
我們快速講
我們今天錄比較快一點
來 我們先跟大家講一件事
看一下喔
那川普提台灣又喊要課晶片稅
這是嘴巴說的而已好不好 OK
他只是說趕快來
趕快來做生意
如果要課早就課了
其實台灣對他是很好
他只是叫台灣趕快過來而已 你懂嗎
如果要賣晶片到美國
就要付100% 200% 50%
隨便多少
他的重點是要在美國
他其實重點是要在美國
建立晶片體系
就這麼簡單
所以你不用理他講這些話
村田停供 昨天工商時報先有嘛
現在經濟日報才有
被動元件迎轉單
所以這真的有機會好不好
只是因為大家現在覺得利多不是利多
現在記憶體利多不是利多
那鎧俠說
現在價格到這邊就好了
已經到頂了
那到頂了就要下去了
大家就這樣解讀
沒有關係 AI會好的
來 我再給你一個未來
雖然今天不應該一直播影片
你們會覺得這不是解股票
這是解股票
我們快速一下
給你來看一下這個差別
我們看一下這個點餐人員
大家看一下
你看喔 這個英文
收音收得到嗎
Is that hot or iced
Hot
講英文 對方是AI嘛
比較頓嘛 對不對
導播有點頓嘛
可是聽得出來是AI對不對
Will that be everything
Yes, that's everything
Before you go
any hash browns
for only two
No, thank you
Your totatis two fifty
他說可以結束了 要走這條路
Hungry Jacks
澳洲很有名的漢堡店
他說你們這些人就是
一小時只付15塊還要Fire他們
These guys are
the first to lose their jobs
他說這些人是第一個
流失工作的人有沒有看到
他意思就是跟你講
他講的話跟我講的一樣
他說AI會取代很多人 你們要準備好
他說他講過了
他說他覺得AI會取代很多人
可是我應該是最早講的
我至少 我全世界不敢講
因為可能英雄所見略同
我是全台灣最懂AI的分析師
哪個分析師說AI會取代很多人
哪個分析師告訴你很多人會失業
現在美國已經開始了
那你再聽一次喔
他點餐喔
Wanna make it large
No
你聽得出來是AI
導播聽得出來對不對
有點慢對不對
有點像機器人的聲音 對
這是這個AI
我們再看另外一個AI
這個AI就是我現在電話的AI
我現在這邊
來 問他
具體功能
這個AI在咳嗽
是AI在咳嗽
他說我來看看
那個人嚇到了
你剛剛是有咳嗽
嗯 對
你講話講到一半還會咳嗽
嗯喉嚨有點癢
你有沒有聽到
他講話講到一半還會咳嗽
咳嗽有點癢
你告訴我 你怎麼分辨的出來
而且這個是有點收訊不好
因為網路的關係嘛
你聽得懂嗎
如果你以後是在
Hungry Jacks
在漢堡店
你不必 你不一定要連網路
你可以自己內建的系統
你不一定要受網路影響
因為你在講話的時候
你是靠網路
你懂不懂
靠雲端伺服器
你可以在這裡我自己建立一個雲端
網路比較穩
他剛才收訊還有點不穩 你聽得懂嗎
可是聲音的節奏
還咳嗽
你根本分不出真假啊
以後很多隔著螢幕做的事情
就是隔著螢幕做的事情
基本上都會被取代
所以你們AI客服人員
我真的希望幫助你們很多人
AI客服人員
很多行政人員
你真的要買AI股
只有這樣子能做而已
所以通膨會下去
只是他會先上去再下去
因為川普就亂搗蛋嘛
那很多人問我今天怎麼辦
你看我今天國巨
一定有人底下留言
為什麼今天心情不好
一定有人底下留言說
哲哲你國巨不是說要漲停
沒有辦法 美股那麼差 是不是
那我能說什麼
就是常常被人家笑
我OK啦 我OK
只是覺得說
最近被詐騙集團 被很多事情
就是大家網友要支持我
要我講一聲
愛我又不疼惜我
看到詐騙集團帳號就幫我檢舉
是不是
也怎麼樣
大家也去連署或怎麼樣
把那些詐騙集團帳號
把臉書給踢出去 真的是很過分
我所謂踢出是說
要求懲罰他們
真的希望立委諸公看到我的節目
因為台灣對臉書太好了
只有罰1500萬才怕一次
你就一直給他罰
罰到最後給他實名制
我們這些名人實名制
就不會很多人
因為我心情很差
我看到100個人因為我
被詐騙集團
詐騙集團很狠耶
是會讓你家破人亡的 你知道嗎
要錢他是要沒底線的 你知道嗎
所以心情有點差
我今天本來不想錄的
但是我還是錄了
因為我要告訴大家
有些未來的知識很重要
很多人要被取代
台灣股市現在因為升息而跌
可是很多人如果失業了
景氣反而會好
很多人失業 通膨反而會怎麼樣
下去 因為他失業
他就是購買力道反而會下滑
會變成貧富差距越來越大
我一定要提醒你們
可是也因為這樣子的關係
股市會漲
就像人家說的 越摳門
有些越摳門的老闆
川湖啊 說很摳門啊
股價越會漲
因為對股東是好 對員工不好
但是我不希望這樣子
至少摩爾不是這樣做
這是我要跟大家講 好不好
所以這些股票都是這樣子 來
所以我要講是說
這幾天 今天晚上
如果CPI晚上8點半公布
3.4%以下會噴
因為已經先跌了嘛
可是3.5% 3.6%是有可能的
我不去預測 太難預測
如果假設到3.6%以上
股市可能會跌 你聽得懂嗎
也有可能會跌下去再拉起來
有可能跌下去再拉起來
可是3.4%以下
如果CPI真的3.4%以下
那我要告訴你
那股市會噴一整天
趕快晚上做期貨
就是CPI只要3.4%以下
漲的機率極高
CPI只要3.5%以上
先跌再說 你懂不懂
而且跌的機率也比上個禮拜
就業數據公布的機率還高
上禮拜是殺下去再拉起來
這禮拜五也有可能殺下去再拉起來
但是機率不高
有可能 這樣聽得懂嗎
我已經推背圖了 對不起
我沒有做字卡
可是今天我用嘴巴說
再講一次 3.4%以下
股市就直接一路漲 好不好
越低越飆
3.5%以上會殺下去
有沒有可能反彈
有可能 但是機率不高
可能殺就直接殺下去了
今天晚上下跌機率高
越高 比如說到3.6%
那就反彈機率更低了
就不要想他會反彈了
這樣好不好 這是我的預測
這個很重要
股票 來 講到股票
聯發科拉回也是要去做多 好不好
真的愛惜哲哲 趕快幫我檢舉
真的 大家把我的意見傳出去
網路上形成言論
詐騙集團太誇張了
100多個帳號
我每天有刪100多個帳號
沒騙你 這個詐騙集團假帳號
底下留言 這是哲哲推薦的LINE
還用我的截圖 扯不扯
這個改天再教 今天太累了
來 所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
現在升息機率72%
算了 我們先講股票
趕快最後講股票
我還是認為拉回就買好不好
昨天5347世界先進
有人說我讓他賺錢
我說哪有賺什麼錢
所以股票就是這樣子嘛
你現在在打第二隻腳
你就趕快買
台灣股市我認為不會跌破4萬點
我有說9月下跌機率比較高嘛 對不對
9月是比較顛簸的
10 11 12月大家確定了
升息或不升息
最壞就這樣子後 股市會拉起來
而且我告訴大家
你剛才有沒有看到
Hungry Jacks
就是那個漢堡店
他的AI是很舊的AI
所以現在是新的AI
明年會更多人取代
所以很多人明年可能會失業
你懂不懂
現在問題是道德的問題
很多人 人生的問題
這已經不是股市問題了
所以我看很遠
韓國已經有這樣子了
台灣銀行的客服以後也都會這樣子
你相信我
只是他是因為法規的關係而已
記住我說的這些東西好不好
精材也是一樣
這個今天有跌
但是他收紅K
算厲害好不好
哲哲 怎麼會這樣子
那個華邦電怎麼要創新高給你殺下去
拉回就做多好不好
我覺得這個底部117不會跌破
你們就不要那麼悲觀好不好
不要那麼悲觀
8299群聯
8299群聯我覺得最誇張
跌什麼 又沒在漲跌什麼
所以今天下影線很明顯有沒有看到
今天下影線很明顯
莫名其妙
你看殺下去又拉起來
他根本沒資格跌
真的我覺得沒資格跌
記住我這句話
3374精材
來 我們看一下
你看緯創
老AI總算不跌了有沒有
2382廣達
缺點就是也沒動
因為現在量縮了 你懂嗎
量縮了 成交量縮了
那當然這些股票
我覺得用力買好不好
國巨我覺得該買還是要買
國巨還有華新科
被動元件有機會再噴出
我認為機率很高
國巨 華新科都是一樣好不好
信昌電都在拉了
都在漲了
記憶體還是很強
被動元件是很強
不論是被動元件 記憶體
甚至是根本就還沒有漲的
這一波根本沒有漲的矽晶圓
我覺得你要勇敢的用力做多
等升息底定後
大家確定
這個利空
等到哪一天利空真的不是利空
我已經理解他升息了
不要一直升 一直升你懂不懂
我理解他升息了
重點是我認為明年的通膨會急速下滑
因為第一個
為什麼
因為有可能伊朗跟美國會和談
到最後還是有可能
第二個最重要是什麼
最重要的是失業率會提高
很多人會因為剛才我講的
漢堡店啊 很多AI客服啊
電話啊 客服人員啊
很多的接線生 還有很多工作
跟工程師會失業
那很多銀行 很多產業會投資AI
那也真的有利潤
那這些人失業
那是不是消費力道會減少
通膨會減少
到時候是一個
只是一個道德問題
大家討論這個問題
可是對股市是好的
我不得不說
所以我擔心的事情發生了
已經在發生了
可是越是發生這些事情
越代表我看的AI是對的
3年內10萬點
一定要拉回用力做多
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
那今天一樣
要不要參加隨便你 好不好
愛護哲哲 好不好
因為我現在覺得對會員比較好
如果是粉絲 不好意思
那就算了
今天晚上
不能說不愛你們
只是我最愛的是會員
今天晚上10點截止
化被動為主動
主動88專案
相信我不論被動元件 記憶體
很多的矽晶圓
很多股票接下來會噴
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我LINE私訊我
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
我還是愛大家
但希望大家也多愛哲哲一點
多按讚
也記得參加我們的會員
化被動為主動
主動88專案
今天晚上截止
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
AI新時代真來臨了
你不要錯過它
不然你會被淘汰
謝謝各位 Byebye